new fans and series veterans alike seem
to love the Dead Space remake so where
does the franchise Go From Here remake
of Dead Space 2 a completely new game in
that world let me know what you would
want in the comments during an interview
with GQ deadspace's senior producer Phil
Ducharme and creative director Roman
combos Ariola shared they are interested
in exploring new ideas on the topic of
bringing back the series in the future
Ducharme said quote it's a hope that we
have there is interest on my side and I
think on Roman side in exploring Dead
Space more there are ideas that's for
sure do charm continued by saying after
making sure that the Remake launches
with as few technical errors as possible
they're going on vacation when they
return they'll sit down with EA and
discuss the future of Dead Space the
developers also discussed how the horror
genre was niche in the mid-2000s but
they think the original game pushed
Horror in the direction of success quote
before it disappeared off the map adding
that the timing is now right for spaces
return the series went away years ago
following the release of Dead Space 3
and the shift from less horror more
action Co-op and even micro transactions
all things that lost the Goodwill of the
fan base now I may not be in love with
the genre but it is nice to see an
offline single-player horror game doing
well in a world where asymmetrical
multiplayer horror games are pretty
popular unlike Dead Space though redfall
is going to require an online connection
on the official redfall FAQ the new
requirement states that a quote
persistent online connection is required
for single player and co-op in that
bethesda.net account will also be
necessary this isn't an unusual move as
many modern games require some form of
online check-in as an anti-piracy
measure or in redfall's case progression
fairness to keep the playing field level
when joining friends in Co-op but this
form of DRM has drawn criticism for
adding extra steps to single player
titles back for blood initially required
a persistent online connection when it
first launched even if you were playing
alongside AI teammates but a later patch
added an offline story mode for the game
other games that have eased off it's
always online requirement include
Marvel's Avengers and it takes two with
those two games offering offline single
player and couch Co-op modes
respectively a new game that won't need
an offline patch is Star Wars Jedi
Survivor but it will need a little more
time in the oven EA announced on January
31st that Survivor has been delayed from
March 17th to April 28th the
announcement came from the EA Star Wars
account via Twitter where Stig osmussen
the game director at respawn
entertainment said the reasoning is to
focus on bug fixes to enhance
performance stability polish and most
importantly the player experience but
the delay is a much better fate than a
complete shutdown EA also announced it
has stopped development on apex Legends
mobile and Battlefield mobile EA claims
it's shutting down Apex mobile because
the ongoing experience was not going to
meet the expectations of our players for
Battlefield mobile it was so that they
could best deliver their vision of the
franchise and meet the expectations of
players those darn expectations always
killing projects in non-ea shutdown news
iron Galaxy announced that Rumble verse
servers will go offline on February 28th
after less than a year of existing a
final update was pushed out on January
31st that closed the in-game store and
opened the entire Rumble verse
experienced players every player will
receive the current battle pass and earn
Double XP additional accessories and
emotes will be unlocked for free as well
players who spend money on Rumble verse
will be able to receive a refund for the
amount spent on or in the game are you
gonna miss Rumble verse are you gonna
miss Battlefield mobile and Apex mobile
and what are you gonna play in March now
that you can't play Jedi Survivor let me
know in the comments I'll see you
tomorrow
foreign